دراما دوك وذوقات ساسكس تبدو انها مستمره
فمن بعد ما تم بث 6 اجزاء من وثائقي هاي
وماجن على منصه نتفليكس وصل الامير هاري
دو ساسك تصريحاته العلنيه والمفاجاه بخصوص
خلافاته مع العائله المالكه واكيد الجميع
تابعه وشاف الجدل اللي عملوه الوثائق
واللي خرب الدنيا وعامر رديت فعل مختلفه
داخل المجتمع البريطاني ويبدا ان هو نحن
على مواعيد متعدده مع الفضائح واستمرار
الجدل الامير هاري بالوقت الناس في عم
تنتظر اصدار كتابه في العاشر من الشهر
الجاري يبدو انا صاصك ما راح يسكت ومستمر
بيهتم الاعلان عن مقابلتين مختلفتين معه
تحترم عرضهم في نفس اليوم واول مقابله
لبرنامج سكس بنت وتعتبر اول مقابله
للتلفزيونيه الامريكيه الامير هاري
مذكراته بيسبير وصلت طفولته
وقال خلال المقطع دعائي في المقابله لانه
في كل مره ولا فيها القيام بشيء على
الانفراد كانت هناك ايحاطات وتسريبات وزرع
قصص ضده وضد زوجته فكم تعلمون شعار
العائله هو لا تشكو ابدا ولا تشرح ابدا
اما التصريح الثانيه العالمي الثاني
للامير هارب هو كمان من خلال مقابله مع
قناه اي تي في البريطانيه واللي كان من
اظهر فيها المقطع ادعائي حاله من الشكوى
العالميه ولكن ضد والد الملك تشارلز واخوه
ولي العهد وليام اللي ما اظهر لا هو ولا
الملك اي استعداد للمصالحه معه لا قال
فيها انه هو عم يبحث عن عائله وليس عن
مؤسسه انه بيرغب باستعادتهم مشاهدينا انه
المقابلتين راح يتم بسهم في نفس التوقيت
قبل يومين من نشر مذكرات الامير الحريري
لموقع انه تحمل قناه جديده حول حياتك يعني
يبدو انه كل هذه الاحداث هو التصريحات لا
شيء امام ما قد يكون مكتوب داخل مذكرات
الامير من عنوانها او الاحتياطي انها تحمل
الكثير من الجدل والمفاجات
وعن هذا الجدل المستمر تنضم الينا من لندن
الصحفيه جولسلين ايليا
اهلا بك جولين
اهلا بك يعني بعد ما كشف كل شيء تقريبا
الامير هاري عن كل خصوصيات العيله
والفضائح الجمهور البريطاني عن جد متشوق
يعرف المزيد من تلك الفضائح ام مال من
كثره الشكاوي يا اللي اطلقها هذه خلال
فتره الاخيره وصار في حاله انتعاض ضده ضد
زوجته
بصراحه ااا نحنا ببريتانيا عم نحضر كانه
وقائع لمسلسل امريكي طويل او مسلسل تركي
اذا صح التعبير لانه في احداث كثير وفي
قنابل كثير وفي نشر غسيل كتير ولكن السؤال
اللي بيطرح نفسه الان قد ايه راح يكون بعد
عنده غسيل حتى ينشروا علنا عن عائله مهم
جدا عائله ملكيه مثل العيله اللي هو
بينحضرنا
انقسام هون بشارع البريطاني الغالبيه همم
تعبه ومن له من هذا الموضوع وفي رده فعل
سلبيه جدا على الامير هاري وعلى زوجته
بالتحديد مجانا يا اللي يقع عليها اللون
الاكبر وبيحسب اغلبيه البريطانيين يرون
على الرغم من كل الي قباحه فيه ولا قلوب
من
[موسيقى]
اه في ممكن فكروا انه في نوع من التعاطف
مع انه هي ما تعاملت بالطريقه الي كان
لازم تتعامل فيها وقصر باكينغهام ما
اعطاها الدعم اللي كان لازم ولكن انقلب
السحر على الساحر ولا اعتقد بانه الشارع
البريطاني او البريطانيين يقفون مع الذي
يجري الان ومع الفضائح المتكلم
الصمت المطبق من العائله المالكي عاده
تسريبات عن العائله المالكي حاليا نرى ان
هناك الصمت مطبق حول الموضوع كيف تقرا هذا
المكان
بحسب بالمقتطفات يا اللي شفناها اليوم
بالنسبه للمقابلتين اللي راح تكون مع
اندرسون كوبر اا من سي بي اس والمقابله
الثانيه مع القناه الثالثه في بريطانيا
اللي بين فيها واللي هو قالوا انه السكوت
هو خيانه وهو يعني الامير هاري الجمله هذه
بانه ماشي تعليق من قصر
الملكه همم
حاليا هي على راسها الملك والدته الملك
تشارلز ولكن اعتقاد بانه اذا قصر
باكينغهام او حتى الملك نفسه
بقضيه القال والقيل والاتي اعظم لانه همم
لن تنتهي السلسله هنا في المقابلتين يوم
الاحد او مساء الاحد وانما هناك يعني بعض
الاخبار التي
راحه في الكتاب في كتاب السبير يوم
الثلاثاء القادم فلا اعتقد بان من مصلحه
الملك تشارج او من قصر باكينغهام التعليق
او او اقل من دقيقه هل ممكن الملك تشارلز
ان يخضع للضغوطات يعني نزع كل الالقاب عن
ابنه
من الممكن لان المساله اصبحت مساله تحدي
ومساله تجاريه همم وما يجري الان واعطاء
يعني القيام بهذه المقابلتين يوم الاحد
ترويش للكتاب الذي دفعوله عليه 20 مليون
دولار
فالمساله اصبحت مساله التجاره فهو يبيع
قصص عائلته للعيش لانه لا يعمل حاليا ضمن
المؤسسه الملكيه التي تركها هو يعني هو
برغبه تركه في الولايات المتحده مع زوجته
ولكن يعني هناك في تناقض كبير همم رايناه
في همم بعض المقتطفات ما في مقابله السي
بي اس بانه هو هو هو طبعا يعيش في
الولايات المتحده لانه يبحث عن الحريه
الشخصيه وعن الخصوصيه
لن ينتحر قريبا شكرا لك من لندن شكرا
جزيلا لك
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]